closing every school in the United
States could cost the economy fifty
billion dollars a month according to new
analysis led by a professor of
Epidemiology at NYU the majority of US
states have already taken this step to
slow the spread of coronavirus and local
governments are weighing the decision
heavily because closing schools has
far-reaching economic and social
implications we spoke to one of the
authors of this report to find out how
they're measuring the impact there's a
lot of uncertainty about how long school
closures would last and also about how
much they'd cost so if you only closed
schools for two weeks the medium
estimate would be twenty five billion
dollars non-trivial but again under 0.1
but roughly 0.1 percent of GDP the four
weeks is 50 billion and it scales more
or less linearly with the duration of
the school closure so the benefit of
school closure is clear but it's also
important to take account of the
potential costs a lot of parents would
miss work to care for their kids and
those people are subtracted from the
labor force one important question is
what's the inequality implication of
this and many of the people who would be
affected are lower income workers who
can't tell a commute and who don't have
alternative means to afford health care
it's also true that lower-income
children often get to 2/3 of their meals
per day in schools and other social
services so it would disproportionately
affect lower strata of the economy one
important group that it would affect is
health care workers themselves the fact
that their health care workers included
in that group also suggests that it
would degrade the response to the
epidemic in the sense that it subtracts
health care workers just at a time when
we need them to deal with this epidemic
so there are benefits of school closures
obviously it reduces transmissions by
pre net preventing contacts it reduces
the peak transmission rate which is
important because the health care system
needs to cope with that and it can
reduce the overall numbers
closing national schools would be the
result of state and local decisions
there's another federal government under
normal conditions does not have the
authority to close all the nation's
schools so this would be the result of
an accumulation of local actions it's
very hard to say how long you'd need to
keep schools closed
there are many uncertainties one of
which is is the extent of the infection
in the population at large because the
testing has not been sufficiently
aggressive we don't really know how much
disease is really out there and one
issue is simply when you close schools
there are still circulating infections
and if you open schools prematurely you
get a second wave and this is what we
actually saw in the famous 1918 Spanish
flu there were very very draconian
quarantines and other measures and
people thought that the disease was more
or less over and it was more or less
over the tricky thing about the
epidemics is they can flare up again
with only a very few infective still
circulating
[Music]